je pense que poutine a tout à fait
raison de faire ce qu'il a fait depuis
une dizaine d'années - d'abord j'estime
que c'est un patriote russe c'est ça que
j'admire d'abord chez lui on est là à
faire un cirque pour parce qu'il a
occupé la crimée excusez-moi poutine
n'est pas un danger pour nous la presse
occidentale passe son temps à faire de
poutine un méchant il faut arrêter de
faire de poutine l'agresseur c'est
poutine l'agresser le provocateur ce
n'est pas tout ils les occidentaux sont
mal venu de critiquer poutine le
problème de l'ukraine n'est pas si vous
voulez que la russie menace d'une
invasion je n'y crois pas c'est lui
l'agressé il faut pas en faire
l'agresseur avec poutine au moins l'état
déliquescent a été restauré la russie a
repris son attitude traditionnelle de
grand frère impérieux avec ses anciennes
possessions le crâne en tête la russie
je vous donne le prend le pas je prends
le pari n'envahira pas l'ukraine je
dirais que poutine ressemble beaucoup il
le répète français oui ce que je veux
dire c'est à dire oui j'aimerais
beaucoup qu'on reçoit alligier avec la
russie pour rêver d'un président
français à oui j'en rêverai je me dis
que c'est pas la france gaullienne que
je défends c'est une france qui ait pas
de goût c'est une france qui est à
genoux